[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui lundi 10
juillet parole à bertrand de créer le
président du medef yvelines nous
parlerons évidemment avec lui de la
réforme du code du travail voulue par
emmanuel macron alors que le débat
parlementaire a débuté aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale parle aussi dans
cette émission à jean françois raynal
vice président du conseil départemental
délégué aux mobilités nous ferons avec
lui le point sur les travaux prévus sur
les routes départementales cet été 70
chantiers sont répartis en tout dans les
yvelines
je me tourne vers mon invité en direct
bertrand de créer bonsoir pourquoi vous
êtes je le disais le président du modef
de medef
le medef dans les yvelines le président
78 est il aujourd'hui rassurés de voir
que le chantier de la réforme du code du
travail est plutôt partie assez
rapidement il a débuté à l'assemblée
nationale vous êtes dans satisfait
aujourd'hui vous un titre personnel ça
d'esprit c'est beaucoup dire vous savez
aujourd'hui on a quoi on a un projet de
loi d'habilitation et fait assez
générales et c'est normal pour un projet
de loi d'habilitation et vous savez en
matière sociale le diable se cache
souvent dans les détails ce qui veut
dire préciser votre votre à leur pensée
par là que nous sommes on se dit c'est
bien le gouvernement va dans le bon sens
mais on pourra se prononcer
véritablement quand on verra vraiment la
rédaction de lens oui ça devrait être
fin juillet début août qu'il veut
petite question on est seulement un an
après la loi elle comme riz est ce que
c'est à dire que la loi d'il ya un an
qui visait déjà à réformer le code du
travail n'a n'a servi à rien à rien
nombre c'était une étape
moi je considérais que la loi ait commis
était une étape mais maintenant il faut
aller plus loin plus en profondeur il ya
des grands chantiers qui vont être
organisées et c'est là qu'on attend
justement que d'ailleurs de son acteur
nous ferons porter la voix de
l'entreprise parce que notre seul souci
à nous c'est de libérer l'on trouvait de
ces contraintes pour développer l'emploi
aujourd'hui nos projets débattus
et pas encore définitive vous le disiez
mont à leux on a le cadre général avec 9
articles précisément parmi eux il ya le
recours au cdi de projets ça serait une
nouveauté en france en tout cas le
généraliser la barémisation des
indemnités prud'homale ou encore
l'élargissement du champ des accords d
entreprise
tout n'est pas arrêté je disais mais ce
que le cadre déjà vous convient est ce
que vous pensez qu'on est quand même sur
une bonne piste est ce que vous mettriez
une bonne note pour l'instant aux hauts
cadres qui est présenté à la 70e tout à
fait que tu as fait encore une fois le
projet général nous satisfaire veux
qu'on mette ces points-là en chantier
d'une bonne chose mais comme je disais
maintenant attendons de voir des le
diable se cache dans les détails
c'est ce que vous disent les aussi les
chefs d'entreprise ils sont satisfaits y
en a quand même certains qui émette des
réserves ou pour l'instant on est quand
même sur une vague
globalement est totalement positive ben
oui nous sommes dans la tente c'est une
attente positive las une espérance c'est
une espérance d'entreprises ont besoin
d'être rassurés aujourd'hui et est
aujourd'hui clairement le gouvernement
nous envoient des messages qui sont
propres à nous rassurer alors pas
satisfaits encore mais rassurés et
pensons que on peut aller si le travail
se fait bien s'il ya pas trop de
dogmatisme en face de nous nous pourrons
arriver à quelque chose de gagnant
gagnant
est ce que vous estimez qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes avec un gouvernement et un
président de la république qui pourrait
répondre le plus favorablement à vos
demandes requête qui sont vieilles de
plus de nombreuses années en tout cas
nous voulons y croire
nous allons y participer vous regrettez
vous répondez quoi à ceux qui disent que
c'est si un projet fait par le medef et
pour le bébé
moi je répondrai que c'est un projet que
fait pour l'entreprise pour la france et
pour l'emploi c'est pas pour le medef le
medef c'est là bas vous savez c'est la
voix de l'entreprise
donc donc à travers sa celle des
salariés selon vous qui pourrait être
plus facilement embaucher mais bien sûr
si c'est pour l'emploi c'est pour
justement coûté la vraie précarité dans
ce monde c'est le chômage
c'est pas c'est pas l'emploi c'est le
chômage la précarité donc réduire le
chômage développer l'emploi c'est
intéressant pour tout le monde
sur le fond dit nous par exemple ce que
vous pensez de la barémisation des
indemnités prud'homale au sextant un
point épineux pour les opposants à ce
projet quel est l'intérêt pour les
employeurs d'avoir intel bat rennes pour
alors aujourd'hui nous sommes face à une
loterie medved loterie
il ya deux points avoir d'abord les
indemnités si on fixe un plancher et un
plafond ça ne gênera en rien la
démonisation du salarié en cas de faute
de l'employeur seulement qu'on saura que
telle faute
amen elle parraine une organisation ce
que ça puisse pas aussi à la faute et se
dire ben je vais prendre des risques
puisque je sais que ça va payer
ça peut rentrer dans ma dans mon
assiette et et finalement je vais
prendre le risque de violer untel ou
untel même si c'est pas légal est ce que
ça peut pas favoriser les licenciements
ces questions je peux sans arrière
pensée ou le répondre est ce que le fait
d'avoir deux de savoir que des peines
pénales ont d'un barème incite à la
photo dit tiens je veux faire un crime
parce que ça va me prendre que trois
grandes prisons belges vivent et non non
mais c'est un art à mon ami c'est un
faux débat ça c'est un faux débat
un chef d'entreprise qui va se dire
tiens je vais m'acheter ça c'est un faux
débat
alors s'il y en a qui résonne comme ça
l'a peut-être on sait jamais mais nous
connais trois ans que je passe à
favoriser la même chose favoriser les
accords d'entreprise plutôt que les
accords de branche ça aussi c'est
quelque chose que lorsque vous appelez
pas tout à fait ce qu'on a dit c'est à
dire que alors qu'on dit qu'il faut en
fait à mener le dialogue au plus près du
terrain
favoriser d'accords d'entreprise c'est
l'accord entre un chef d'entreprise et
son équilibre comme savoir que 90 % le
même 97 pour l'entreprise française sont
des pme et que 90 pots d'entreprise
n'ont pas de syndicats
les accords se font dans les entreprises
entre des patrons qui ont des poils 3 4
5 6 7 8 salariés
il ya une grande proximité entre le
patron et son employé
et contrairement à ce que disent
certains n'y a pas cette volonté de
vouloir peser ou causer du tort à à ses
employés cette relation là elle est
selon vous c'est dans une pme elle elle
est complètement manichéenne et
complètement d'un autre âge
si vous voulez dans une équipe
aujourd'hui vous savez je pense
représenter assez bien les patrons de
pme j'étais même salarié ya une
quarantaine d'années
j'ai créé mon entreprise après quarante
ans j'étais salarié je suis chef
d'entreprise et c'est le cas de beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs en france on travaille
d'abord avec des petites équipes puis si
la chance vous sourit avec nos équipes
ont grandi avec eux il ya une relation
qui est très différent dans nos pme
moi j'ai des idées de cadeaux rabatteurs
qui sont avec moi depuis le début alors
sont pas des amis que des copains et
récents des relations qui compte pour
moi sont des gens pour qui compte pour
moi et je pense que je compte pour eux
et c'est ça des relations d'entreprise
une dernière question peut être pour se
projeter sur le futur selon vous quelle
est l'autre priorité pour le
gouvernement pour pour surfer sur cette
vague du chômage qui commencent à
baisser ce ce cette économie qui semble
repartir enfin qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire
ensuite après la réforme du code du
travail est ce que baisser les impôts
sur les sociétés jusqu'à 25% c'est déjà
une bonne chose
alors c'est vraiment engagements qu'a
pris le président il a dit qu'il le
ferait avant la fin de son septennat
alors c'était pas des points
d'accrochage qu'on a nous aujourd'hui
ces grosses liasses fiscales sont pas
assez rapides donc bravo pour nous au
travail
la fiscalité devrait suivre et notamment
la fiscalité sur les sur les charges qui
pèsent sur le travail sur l'emploi
merci bertrand de créer d'avoir été en
plateau avec une merci pour vos réponses
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
medef 78 merci à vos murs morose et
l'été il ya souvent moins de véhicules
sur les routes du département les
yvelines en profitent du goût pour
rénover de nombreux axes de circulation
amélioration de la sécurité mise en
place de liaisons
sous répartition aussi des chaussées
mélanie poké charline hurel font le
point sur les travaux prévus pour ces
estivales 2017 avec jean françois raynal
le vice président du conseil
départemental concerne jean françois
raynal bonjour vous êtes aujourd'hui là
pour nous parler des travaux d'été du
département ce que vous gérez 1600 km il
ya plus de 70 chantiers cet été vous
avez déjà tout résumé effectivement 1600
km qui appartiennent ou qui sont de la
responsabilité du département des
yvelines est tous les ans on profite de
l'été pour deux raisons la première la
densité de circulation
on est dans une période où il y a moins
de circulation
ensuite la météo on peut imaginer et
aujourd'hui c'est le cas c'est plus une
journée de canicule d'avoir une météo
conforme pour pouvoir engager ces
travaux les travaux sont de plusieurs
natures d'abord l'entretien de notre
patrimoine parce que la route c'est
aussi un patrimoine du département est à
peu près une centaine de kilomètres vont
être rénovés reflète surtout la bande de
roulement qui va être refaite c'était
une nouvelle couche de bitume pour faire
simple travaux de nuit travaux qui se
font parfois en circulation alternée
notre objectif bien qu'il y ait une
densité de circulation plus faible c'est
pénaliser le moins possible l'usagé tout
ça en concertation bien évidemment avec
les communes puisque vous dites 70
chantiers ça veut dire que et la carte
tout à l'heure que vous avez regardé
montre que ces chantiers sont
complètement dispersés sur le territoire
donc ça c'est la première forme et c'est
une enveloppe de 10 millions d'euros que
tous les ans nous essayons de maintenir
et que nous maintenons pour pouvoir
entretenir notre patrimoine
ce sont des petits chantiers la conte
dont vous parlez donc on parle
d'enrobage ckoi réfection de chaussée
remise en place de barrières de sécurité
peut-être chez avant tout la bande de
roulement
après ça peut être des travaux pour
améliorer un carrefour
ça va être aussi effectivement les
allées les bas côtés de la route est
parfois s'il faut refaire des rails de
sécurité ou des barrières de protection
on en profite pour les rénover mais
c'est surtout la chaussée à laquelle
nous nous intéressons ce que vous dites
petits travaux c'est quand même des
travaux
assez lourd parfois on va jusqu'à couper
la circulation pendant une ou deux
semaines pour vraiment intervenir
correctement quand on le peut je le
disais à l'instant on essaye de
travailler de nuit ont fait des travaux
préparatoires dans la journée et la nuit
on coupe la circulation et en étant le
nouvelle couche de bitume
ça c'est la première opération une
deuxième opération aussi que nous
faisons et on en profite de le faire
pendant l'été là encore parce que il y à
une moindre circulation donc on va moins
gênés l'usagé et souvent ça se fait en
zone urbaine c'est les travaux de
sécurité
la sécurité routière c'est fondamental
quand il y à des zones dites
accidentogène on essaye de les résorber
on ne le fait pas seul on le fait en
partenariat bien évidemment avec les
communes parce que vous imaginez bien
que si vous intervenez dans un axe au
coeur d'une ville il faut quand même
qu'on le prépare ensemble et le
financement est partagé avec la région
parce qu'il y à des programmes justement
de sécurité et cet été ça va être de
l'ordre de 2 millions et demi qui ont
été votées à la dernière séance et qui
vont être mis en place
donc ce sont des travaux qui sont sur
beaucoup plus ciblée parfois c'est un
carrefour que l'on refait c'est un
aménagement avec des chicanes on
améliore le la traversée pour les
piétons puisqu'on considère et on essaye
de protéger tous les usagers il ya bien
évidemment les véhicules à moteur
mais il ya aussi des cyclistes il y a
les piétons et en ville on sait que la
coexistence
ce n'est pas toujours simple et il faut
qu'on contribuer à l'améliorer il y a
donc ses chantiers la pire l'un des plus
gros notre invention
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plaisir la
rd30 ça en est où
alors là ce sont des chantiers qui sont
d'une autre nature puisque là nous
créons où nous refaisons des voiries
mais sur des chantiers qui s'étale dans
le temps on parlait de l'élargissement
doublement du cd 30-22 la route
départementale 30 au coeur de la ville
de plaisir
en gros c'est relier le bassin de poissy
jusqu à elancourt c'est à dire d'aller
vers la
rn 12 eh bien ce sont des travaux qui
vont s'étaler sur à peu près quatre ans
et on arrive dans la dans le dernier
tiers de ces travaux travaux lourds
travaux onéreux travaux compliqué là
aussi en pleine circulation
mais petit à petit on va je dis pas
qu'on va voir le bout du tunnel parce
qu'il n'ya pas de tunnel sur le chantier
même s'il ya une partie un petit peu
couvertes mais voilà on y arrive on y
arrive et c'est un gros gros chantier il
nous restera deux passerelles à réaliser
là encore je fais une relation avec les
circulations douces
puisque nous sommes aujourd'hui sur but
avec cette piste cyclable et c'est pas
un hasard si on a voulu que ce point de
presse se fasse justement là aussi dans
d'autres formes de déplacement que sont
les circulations douces la passerelle
que nous allons faire au coeur de la
ville et l'autre qui enjambera la rn12
c'est pour faciliter le déplacement en
toute sécurité piétons et cyclistes
vu que vous faites 100 km chaque année
il ya 1600 km vous avez une boucle à
faire peut-être en gros c'est ça c'est
un schéma mais c'est vrai que si vous
voulez entretenir votre patrimoine à
part des aléas particulier parce qu'on
peut avoir un jour un accident
particulier sur une chaussée mais on
essaye de faire en sorte de programme et
dans le temps de telle sorte que notre
parc routier soit toujours du même
niveau
on maintient un bon niveau de qualité
d'entretien du parc routier
si vous le faites régulièrement ça vous
coûte au moment où vous le faites mais à
l'arrivée ça vous coûtera moins cher que
si vous avez attendu
j'avais un peu comme le ravalement d'une
maison aura je vais pas le faire cette
année et vous le faites dix ans après et
ça vous coûte dix fois plus cher
merci et jean françois raynal et pour
découvrir tous les lieux et les dates
concernés par ces travaux
direction le site yvelines point fr
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
pour ce soir prochain rendez vous demain
même heure excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]
et